that's life. Allow us to enjoy the magic of music. What happens when we hear an instrument played. What happens is that waves are created in the air that surrounds us. And these expanding ripples of pressure are the sound detected by our ears.
This makes the eardrum vibrate.
The eardrum, in turn, transmits the signal to a tiny bone called the hammer,
which beats on another bone known as the anvil.
Third bone, the stirrup, passes on the amplified vibrations to the inner ear.
Here we find the cochlea and these ultra-sensitive hairs, the corti organs,
which tremble with every vibration.
Sodium-ion messengers swim about in a state of readiness.
Inside the cell, there is much activity.
Just like the normal hustle and bustle we've seen in other cells.
When we penetrate the nucleus, we find a control room devoted to the measurement of sound.
These are medium-loud vibrations of about 80 decibels.
Let's get them recorded, polarize the cell, let the sodium ion messengers in.
They'll pass the signal on for us.
Huh?
I can't hear anything. They told me I was assigned to a sound transmission unit.
That's absolutely right.
Why is it so quiet then?
Because we don't hear anything, you see.
Our job is transmitting vibrations.
Their frequency, their amplitude, that's it.
I think I see what you mean.
I suppose it must be the brain that turns the vibrations into sound.
Yes, that's where they do the hearing.
The screen. You can see the walls of the cell out there.
Watch for the sodium ion messengers.
Their job is to help the neurotransmitters.
All right, where to now?
Thought you and you.
What a shambles. Who's in charge?
I've got it, guys.
The neurotransmitters are this way.
This way!
Come on, push, push harder!
Some sodium ions don't pull their weight.
I'm not one of them.
Why don't you save your breath for pushing?
Chaps, we're almost there!
Unload the neurotransmitters for the auditory nerve!
That's how it's done.
First of all, we register the vibrations, then pass them on as auditory nerve impulses to the brain.
So that's hearing, is it?
Not by a long joke, my lad.
You see, the signals we send can only be interpreted by the brain itself.
And the messages we transmit have still got an awful long way to travel.
Messages carried along the nerve cell until it reaches the nucleus with a control room very similar to our own.
And when things are quiet outside, they're quiet inside it as well.
This harmonic wave is only 65 decibels.
P.D., your job is delivering messages, not reading them.
Now take it to the eighth auditory nerve.
In the hurry, she'll be put away for life.
Message coming through.
Turns up the nerve cell until it has to jump to the next cell, the junction.
See the message relayed from cell to cell along the auditory nerve.
Finally, the impulse reaches the brain, where it's converted into the sound we hear.
Groove, daddy-o, in the groove. Wonderful, isn't it?
Simple sound vibrations, that's all they are.
But when the ear has picked them up and the brain has processed them, they're pure magic.
How the brain does it is a bit of a mystery, but what a marvel all the same.
They say that music comes a savage breast, but personally I find it rather stimulating.
Lobus lost your sea legs.
Something bothering you, Liv.
There's something very wrong in this section, Captain.
Well, your hunches are usually right.
Lead the way, Lieutenant.
That earthquake.
A drum, you see.
Three little bones, the hammer, the anvil, and the stirrup.
Maybe the smallest bones in the volley, but they amplify the vibrations two times.
Who's that?
It's all very well, but here we are, climbing up a dark, slippery tunnel.
We don't even know where we are.
I know where we are, numskull.
In the Eustachian tube.
It links the nose to the ear, which is where we're headed.
Why the ear, huh?
I tell you why.
It's a nice, quiet place where we can creep in undetected.
To have a leader with brains like me, we're going to set up our beautiful otitis.
What's that?
You ignorant slob, you don't even know what otitis is.
Idiotitis is an ear infection that young kids get all the time.
Let's move along.
Hold it.
I don't like the look of that.
Bite yourselves.
Down there, Captain. Do you see them?
Yes, Lieutenant. Let's move in closer.
Calling all antibody troops.
Report immediately to right your station tube to repel large invasion force of Staphylococcus germs.
I repeat, report to right your station tube to repel large invasion force of Staphylococcus germs.
Message received, we're on our way, over and out.
We can keep it undetected, he said.
Mission accomplished, Captain, no problem.
We're more than a match for those hulking great Staphylococcus thugs.
Yes, indeed, Metro. It looks as though we've nipped that one in the bud.
Funny. I had a pain in my ear, but it's gone away now.
You seem to be getting on quite well with your piano lessons.
Are you finished now?
We're riding our bikes.
Good idea. We can take a ride over to the park and back again.
Droppy, there's no cops in sight.
They're himself killed.
What do you think you're flapping?
Because it's a very loud noise, 140 decibels, it's painful.
We'd better send it through urgently.
Use normal channels for 140 decibel noise like that.
What we need is a priority pain messenger.
Thanks.
So many pain signals at once, it's abnormal.
Could there be some mistake?
Or do you think we should send a message to block the ears?
We can't take that sort of decision.
It has to be handled upstairs.
So let's get on and transmit those pain messages.
Ours not to reason why, I'm afraid.
Ours but to do our job.
So let's get to work.
Work like a slave and where does it get you, huh?
While whippersnappers like him get promoted to the flying squad.
Question of fashion.
Is it the in thing to wear leathers and a helmet these days?
That's it!
Why on earth didn't I think of it earlier?
Just watch me.
I'm about to join the very latest fashion trend.
Him, didn't I?
We'd be delighted to come forward as witnesses
if you decide to prosecute those reckless children.
The lights were red.
Traffic lights were green, weren't they?
Well, maybe they were amber.
Don't you agree, Strobby?
And that's not all.
Just how fast do you think you were going?
Well, we weren't speeding.
We were doing 30 or 40 at the outside.
And your horn, it's a regulation hooter, I suppose,
even though it's still ringing in my ears.
Exceeding the speed limit,
failing to stop at a red light,
and using an illegal warning device.
Now, what about your license?
If you can't produce your license,
you're really in hot water.
Working down here, but now I can't stand it.
I just can't stand it.
The noise is driving me mad.
I can't bear it much longer.
It's driving me crazy.
The noise is going to destroy me.
Not 'til you've dealt with all these signals, young man.
What's going on here, Chris?
Thank you. You'd best be on your way.
Oh, I'm not trying to make trouble, sir.
It's just that I don't understand what's happening.
My dear young chap, sounds are only vibrations.
And when the vibrations become too strong, they hurt.
The pain is meant as a danger signal to warn us.
A danger signal?
Yes, it all goes back to the times of the cavemen.
Of course, in those days, our hearing was much more acute.
Years ago, sound is still a warning to us in modern time.
A phone could be a warning for...
The pain tells you that your hearing is in danger.
See, the receptor cells are fragile and noise can shatter them.
Nowadays, we know how to protect ourselves against harmful noise.
But some of us don't know just how harmful it can be.
Already, I'm afraid.
There's nothing we can do to bring it back and he'll have to be very careful in the future.
What can he do, Doctor?
Lower volume for shorter periods, that's my advice.
Too much noise causes stress and destroys the sensory cells in the ears.
The damage can never be repaired.
The hearing loss is permanent.
Message for the nervous system, increase the rate of heartbeat immediately.
Message for the lymphatic nervous system, constrict the capillaries.
Message for the endocrine glands, increase secretion of adrenaline with immediate effect.
There you are.
Bye for now, young fellow. I'll talk to you again soon.
Do you see how too much noise can affect your health?
So do take good care of your ears.
I just want to lose their balance.
Okay, let's try.
Point to me.
Not so easy going slow and trying to keep your balance.
Do we keep...
Well, here again, we use our ears.
It's our ears that help us maintain our balance.
Or at least a very special part of the ears called the vestibular apparatus.
Our old friend, Professor Globus, is taking some young corpuscles on a guided tour of the area.
Why don't we join them?
In fact, balance is a sense in its own right, isn't it?
And those are its semicircular canals.
You see? How'd you like that?
As I was saying before...
What was that earthquake, professor?
Must have been a movement of the head. Look!
The head moves. The sensory cells inside the canals can detect this movement.
The movement has been...
Head is tilted forward 15 degrees.
Amid sodium ion messengers to activate neurotransmittance.
Port states that the field of vision has shifted lower down, sir.
I have a message from the neck muscles.
The head is tilting slightly.
According to this message, pressure is increasing on the left knee joint.
Why won't you go in?
Ah, that's better.
Chant signals from the semi-circular canals.
The head is tilted 15 degrees forward.
I think he ought to turn the handlebars.
He should push down on the pedal instead.
In my opinion, he should shift forward in the saddle.
Now, I don't agree with that at all, Chief.
Enough of this chatter.
Our job is to send those signals upstairs.
He'll fall off his bike if we fall behind with our work.
How moved!
The organ of hearing, but as we've just seen, that's not all.
With the vestibular apparatus and its semicircular canals, the ear is also the organ of balance.
Without our ears, we could never stand up, let alone ride a bike.